ok ok élargit encore donné aux caméras
[Musique]
c'est bon on tremble
de là haut
ok ok gauche toi zones zones sèches 8,19
tiré sur 10 9 sur 19
[Musique]
c'est pas bon ça est seul aux grandes
droite gauche et la caq 1 action ans
maximum la maison dès 2000 le moins voir
sa gueule choisi fait combien d'aller
vite déjà 2000 on voit mois sa gueule je
vois rien ce cash
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partage du service minimum
et que vont être fous tu ne montres et
sa gueule oui ou merde
[Musique]
11 21
on tire une carte 2000 et voilà on
peut-être rattrapé ses pairs
[Musique]
j'ai la forme que tu vois
voilà
[Musique]
ceci m'amène
ouais c'est ça
[Musique]
rester là
tu as quelque chose
non j'ai rien du tout dans l'est sur ses
bases
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on veut c'est ne plus vouloir
d'un secteur de classe que vous parler
préférant que nos invités gagne par
hasard plutôt que par calcul
monsieur le professeur barhoum
rien
[Musique]
le cema deviner vous étiez en train de
trouver le moyen de nous rembourser
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire ici
c'est un milieu de travail tellement
[Musique]
prestigieux qu'est ce que vous voulez
sont au courant de tout votre nom votre
façon de fonctionner vos martingale ils
ont même noté vos tics nerveux
vous êtes foutu je juge avait trouvé un
autre déguisement c'est tout vous votre
visite il est achevé
alors il faut nous rendre
notre mise de fond mon cher
je suis un peu je suis appelé à court de
liquidités j'ai eu une mauvaise passe
vous nous devez 40000 je vous signal oui
mais comment je vais arriver à les
gagner moi si vous me couper les vivres
ce n'est pas mon problème écoutez vous
pourriez en faire cadeau je vous ai
rapporter pas mal d'argent depuis des
années vous ne voulez pas que je me met
en colère
attendez une seconde je veux mes
quarante mille et vous n'avez pas oublié
le taux d'intérêt usuraires la vo déjà
qualifiés oui elle attendait j'ai une
idée je crois que j'ai trouvé le moyen
de vous rembourser
oui vous êtes comme eux ces chevaux de
course foutu sur lesquels vous avez tant
parier et dilapidé votre argent
non tout ce qu'on vous a interdit
l'entrée du casino qui allez vous
envoyez votre place un robot
télécommandé peut-être en quelque sorte
je pourrais former une équipe
intéressant oui une équipe de concours
de cartes s'est plaint de forains mathis
il y en a partout
vous prendriez des étudiants oui et
c'est pour ça qu'ils réussiraient jamais
on les soupçonneraient brion c'est
l'unique façon de récupérer votre argent
mais vous êtes fou qu'est ce que vous
faites nous le récupèrerons notre h à
ses côtés et écoutez moi moi j'ai un
doctorat en analyse multidimensionnelle
d'accord les pauvres imbéciles qui
dirige le casino ou un certificat en
gestion de jeux et paris ont redonné
écoutez écoutez moi elle fonctionnera
cette équipe je trouve important qualité
de créancier de laisser un souvenir
marquant mais débiteur je vais réfléchir
à votre proposition
un chirurgien pas trop maladroits vous
leur accommodera
[Applaudissements]
échec et mat puisque j'ai fait une
erreur et j'en arrive et q4 capri qui a
battu trois cas les trois ans 8,5 qu'un
privé mais a pipé ouais c'est la tire
vers la brèche
rendons grâce à dieu pour ses bienfaits
[Musique]
vous apprenez les décimales de pi
j'essaie dire ne vous dérangez pas pour
moi à garder votre sang toi science
ouais mais il faut que je sois ceci non
j'y arrive pas à y est intéressant vous
êtes à combien de décimales ont à peu
près 70
la banane chabane arbres chapeau paix la
corniche en parapluie rocher zèbres
c'est bon j'ai gagné mes 40 dollars
mais votre champ d'étude bas j'ai pas
encore choisi ma spécialité alors c'est
assez étendue donc vous avez un peu de
temps libre
[Musique]
l'esprit de la vie ce que ça implique
je vous écoute je m'excuse monsieur est
un peu compliqué on verra d'accord je
voudrais une pizza mais je dirais avec
des portions différente si ça peut faire
votre bonheur
d'accord alors une pizza avec des
champignons partout sur le fond et sur
une moitié j'aimerais du pepperoni et
sur l'autre on va dire désolé noir site
ou non et c'est là que ça se complique
un petit peu une fois cette étape
franchie j'aimerais que le cuisinier
fasse faire à la pizza un quart de tour
atassi hémisphérique de 90 années
vous êtes en maths oui il ya pas mal de
clients alors oui vous avez bon alors
après le quart de tour ce que j'aimerais
beaucoup c'est sur une moitié des à
l'hiver tandis que sur l'autre je
voudrais du mécano je peux changer un
truc au lieu du pepperoni je peux avoir
de la saucisse
ok mais y'aura supplément au ca et au
lieu des olives noires de la nama au
fonds régional vous avez quelque chose
attendez vous avez vraiment retenu tout
ça ouais vous voulez une pizza avec des
champignons partout saucisses d'un côté
on en a de l'autre à 190° olives vertes
sur nouvelle demi et b qu'une sur
l'autre qui fait qu'on a deux boursiers
avec ceux-ci champignon est allé vers 2
avec champignons et liberté un âne à
deux avec champignons des quais nana et
de saucisses champignons benneteau
devrait justement je voudrais aussi la
bière 2 03 à 0 1 0 - 1 - 2 - 1 0 les
remarques vous vous avez commencé à 0
est finie aussi 1 0
c'est un système trineer où je pense
vous avez donné une valeur positive aux
cartes entre 2 6 7 8 et 9 valeur zéro et
du 10 alain c'est devenu valeur négatif
théorie tout incident d'accord je vais
vous dire quelque chose qui doit rester
strictement confidentiels
bien sûr je suis un compteur de cartes
un quoi j'ai un système qui prévoit les
cartes à venir à une table de blackjack
j'ai déjà gagné beaucoup et le casino
veut plus voir votre hischier comté
n'est pas tricher c'est utiliser sa
matière grise pour réussir mieux que les
autres disent ils il ça mais très vite
les casinos en colère et ce truc 0
négatif c'était quoi une sorte ça donne
une idée des cartes susceptibles de
suivre et tu as juste et paris donc
c'est pas fondées sur la mémoire non
même si tu memories toutes les cartes
kits ont été présentés la plupart du
temps le blackjack se joue avec quatre à
six paquets d'une part pour réduire le
temps brassage et d'en avoir plus pour
vos plumes et mais aussi pour rendre la
mémorisation impossible c'est pourquoi
le comptage simple reste encore le
meilleur système
ça vous donne davantage de prévoir mes
cartes officielles d'ailleurs pourquoi
on est là non parce que je veux vous
apprendre l'art de conter les cartes
c'est vrai pour des points non pour de
l'argent
vous voulez qu'on joue à votre place si
on le fait bien ce n'est pas un jeu
c'est débile tuquoi il voit qu est ce
que tu préfères servir des bières et de
la pizza pour des pourboires ou ramener
mille dollars en liquide chaque soir
pour avoir fait un peu de maths
attendez vous avez dix mille dollars en
une soirée au début oui plus sans doute
si cette jeune femme se joint à l'équipe
parce qu'on ferait équipe
oui et ça marchait mieux comme ça non
mais réfléchi écoute tu payes ton loyer
des frais de scolarité et en plus tu
peux changer de vêtements accordez-moi
juste une demi heure de votre précieux
temps par plus tard au fait je m'appelle
georges salut moi c'est scott réseau
retraite pour s'enterrer je vous
présente des listes salue les pins que
c'est un génie de lits à ckoi s'allie à
l'intelligence artificielle les robots
et abstraction
on dit que les chasseurs de têtes de
corps apparaît mais tu paye tout est
frais pas de bourse rien qui pourrait
t'aider pourquoi les gens qui sont prêts
à vous financez attendent généralement
retour sur l'investissement
qu'est-ce que vous avez audois de les
conseiller dans une règle à calcul
donc un casino que vous expulsez si vous
gagnez trop et qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on perd trop au casino on ne peut
jamais trop perdre
voici comment une équipe peut
fonctionner il faut d'abord un joueur on
va dire genre voilà de place ici comme
ça et deux autres sont les compteurs de
soutien le compteur de soutien trouve
une table ou le coût qui est bien et il
fait comme s'il était là par hasard
il observe le choc il intéresse mais il
n'est pas encore prêt à penser qu'elle a
regardé et comment cet accord mettons
pas un arriviste attention en même temps
il vérifie toujours le nombre d'attaqués
ce cas restants dans le sabot parce
qu'il devra / se lance alors à +1 10 ans
et il reste deux paquets dans le sabot
ce qui nous donne un compte deux plaisir
bien sûr toile
le stis alors simultanément et ne peut
se tenir à compte exact du nombre
d'inscrits
il ya une série de positions de pied qui
viennent on n'a pas un hôpital exact de
zioui ce qui veut dire que seagate
beaucoup des petites cartes de jouer et
qu'il reste tout un paquet durant une
grosse carte
c'est là que voici ya les autres en
croisant les bras ou on vous touche en
la jouant pour passer en amènera les
cheveux n'importe quoi dans votre a
réagi puisqu'il réussit il s'approche la
table il société et puis ce même s'il
est au courant qu'on appelle c'est que
vous lui avez donné un second signal
positif aux besoins caloriques bourges à
pleuvoir mettant ce qui va signifier
plus disent si vous êtes touché mais ce
sera pour motif ce que vous avez dit
alors il s'agit des 10 et dès le départ
il s'est jeté trop longtemps simplement
on connaît maintenant les conditions
d'un sable il paraît maintenant s'il
s'agit d'un joueur si pour 5 $ à la fois
que soudas ils commencent à miser 100
dollars coupe pour les gens du casino le
type est en train de compter mais sinon
on dirait juste un nouveau joint aux as
qui a de la chance il n'y a pas de quoi
s'affoler alonso jusqu'à ce que le
confirmera ses cartes il reste il
ramasse ses gains se lève et se dirige
tranquillement vers une autre table ou
l'autre qu'on te soutient alors disons
que c'est eric c'est toi qui vas côté
pendant qu'elle regarde pour embrasser
elle observe attentivement barils à
suivre les quarts
cependant l'opération est là elle
commence tout de suite à jouer parce
qu'elle sait quels sont les quartiers
vont tomber
elle peut donc miser goût d'été est-ce
que c'est clair maintenant n'oubliez
surtout jamais que le casino vous
surveille ils sont des caméras d'ici ils
sont capables de lire la marque de
commerce sur mon lentilles cornéennes
ils ont des logiciels qui peuvent
analyser votre système de mise en temps
réel les yeux avec chacun bleu qu il
voit si vous observez les cartes d'un
autre joueur ou sivos kangoo bas de la
côte elle vous servent à suivre
attentivement le décompte
s'il croit que vous coûter ils vont tout
faire pour décanter et vous recevrez les
consommations gratuites
le chef de section viande a ouvert la
conversation le couple qui se mettra à
brasser d'où les documents et changeront
de courrier pour un autre trop rapide ou
trop lent
ils feront tout comme n'importe quoi
pour vous faire taire d'entrée mais vous
ne vous ferez pas avoir comme ça avant
parce que vous êtes plus intelligent que
je suis a brillé une faune bière je suis
en génie informatique à conception
système de toit économie physique et
arts de la scène ce spécial comme
combinaison mais bon ça doit être parce
que je veux pas avoir un vrai boulot
après l'université
alors vous avez envie de le faire vomir
je n'en sais rien c'est intrigant en
tout cas ouais mais réfléchissez on n'a
rien à perdre c'est lui je trouve un peu
survoltée
ouais et puis après j'ai pas confiance
désolé mais on peut gagner 1000 $ par
jour ça on n'en est pas sûr mais ça vaut
le coup de s'y c'est l'organisation ça
me paraît élémentaire non mais attends
c'est même pas illégal qu'est ce qu'ils
disaient que si nous coincer
l'interdiction d'y remettre les pieds
c'est tout c'est vraiment ce qui peut
nous arriver de pire
moi je dis qu'on devrait foncé
ok ok ok j'en sais rien
[Musique]
3 valets de 8 9 7 8 10 dames 9 à 5,5
valais super vous êtes tous là on a une
question à 20,1
disons qu'on le fasse qu'on gagne au
paquet de fric on se le partagent commun
j'ai 50 % ils le restent bien voulu
partager 50% mais on fait tout le boulot
si on est si mal hein qu'est ce qui nous
empêche de le faire tout ça oui mais
vous n'avez pas de fonds de roulement
combien de temps vous pouvez tenir le
coup combien vous pouvez vous permettre
de perdre avant d'être lessivé tous les
trois ouais mais on n'a aucune raison de
perdre si on sait quand et pas vraiment
plus naturellement vous perdrez c'est
inévitable le truc c'est quelques pertes
et de nombreux gains bien sûr si vous ne
commencez à l'iseca coût de 10 $ ça vous
prendra du temps et comment vous serez
combien on a gagné dans la soirée eh
bien je serai là ils ont pas expulser
non mais si vous voulez pas le feu à
vous le dites bon allons-y
casino ne sont pas des endroits de
galles
même dans le cas où le plus total il
faut garder le monde est gentil rick
parle
les annonces des croupiers
ces services qui prennent les commandes
les tiens peuple et pas le scot et tout
le reste
et bientôt je veux plus vous entendre
compter
un peu même plus voir voler rebouché
alors règle numéro 1
miser gros quand vous gagnez et peu
quand mon père est évident oui c'est
évident et 10
sauf que c'est plus dur à faire qu'on
croit celui-ci plus de plus trop
[Musique]
confiance dans la stratégie
il faut savoir quand vous frappez vous
maintenez le croupier montre insectes
j'ai déçu alors je dis non au pied en
revenant vers gaza
[Musique]
monsieur le professeur barnes monsieur
hors ca va montrer
bonjour monsieur mademoiselle quand même
sur non
c'est à vous qu'il faut demander ça
[Musique]
ce mr
c'est notre investisseur
il veut s'assurer que vous êtes frais
quel investisseur il faut des sous pour
musée et non c'est une formalité
alors ils vont éblouir ses seins soient
pas inquiet
[Musique]
alors en tirer
direct
gérer
j'arrête j'arrête
j'aimerais faire une main
d'accord j'arrête sur les deux
georges
[Musique]
c'est georges legros piémont 3,4
ouais
geoffrey d'étoilés tu t'arrêtes oui
pardon une petite absence sais rien mais
en attendant c'est tout ce qu'il faut
pour détruire le boulot de ses deux
acolytes
je vous l'avais dit je n'aime pas qu'on
me regarde réfléchir tu veux répéter
allée georges blazy
bon d'accord j'ai fait une erreur mais
ça va maintenant
le conte est à -7 je suis prêt
je m'arrête sur celui là et je tire une
autre carte 15 j'arrête
16 c'est comme si à viry le groupe y
ajouter
je suis moins cons que j'en ai l'air
[Musique]
c'est à biel était donc moi
sauf qu'il est plutôt inquiétant son
investisseurs tu trouves pas ouais et
j'aime pas qu'il y ait d'autres les gens
courant alors une tranche de dix mille
pour commencer on verra pour la suite je
suis sûr que ce soit vite remboursé ce
n'est pas un prêt nous sommes
partenaires partenaires je veux 75 % de
votre part vous êtes mal placés pour
négocier mon cher et l'équipe générera
plus de revenus que vous ne l'auriez
imaginé ce qui peut vous laisser une
part nous dirons plus que généreuse je
suis surpris qu'un professeur de
mathématiques se révèle si naïf sur la
question monétaire mme mais avant que je
n'oublie je vous rappelle que vous me
devez 40 mais je sens que je vais allez
vouloir très bientôt
félicitations à tous ces faits nous
allons avoir notre bourse ouais ouais
super quand est-ce qu'on commence dès
demain soir
ok mais avant de poursuivre nous avons
un dernier détail à régler vos
personnages une aux personnages comme au
théâtre comme scott un toi tu es
représentants de commerce d'accord
nommant une ville que tu connais assez
pour en parler vancouver parfait un
représentant de vancouver de passage ici
pour affaire qui fait un tour au casino
trouve une cravate rose art lise toi tu
es une professionnelle avant kate
non tu es l'unesco ou à une escorte qui
a de la classe ouais non quoi mais non
ça va pas non écoute une jolie jeune
femme seule au casino qui se baladent en
regardant les gens misent et les hommes
ne lâchera pas une seconde mais pas
citer une [ __ ] les hommes sont intimidés
par les buts alors tout à l'heure
j'étais escorte et je suis une [ __ ]
maintenant c'est pas non non non
d'accord il ya un type moins timide qui
se lancent et qui m'abordent bras où on
fera plus d'argent jericho l'aller ça
n'arrivera pas sur toi public voyons pas
dans ces conditions
fais moi confiance et lycées le
camouflage de plus sûres et toi georges
tu es un fils de riche extravagant de la
côte du pacifique qui dépensent le
pognon que lui file son père et je suis
pas un bon menteur si j'étais morte et
nous c'est vrai on va se demander où un
étudiant d'université trouve des
milliers de dollars pour aller jouer au
blackjack et s'est pas trop bien parlé
pourquoi ce serait mieux que telle aire
- disons habile comme ça quand tu auras
une de tes petites absences ça
surprendre à moi alors j'ai moi au fait
dans les stéréotypes minable et scott
c'est le type normal c'est ça c'est
parce que les gens que vous êtes
vraiment tous les deux ne ferait pas une
chose comme ça voilà qu'est ce que ça
veut dire écoute tu vas être nerveuse
mal à l'aise et il vaut mieux que les
gens croient que c'est parce que tu
cherches un client et toi je t'assure
très honnêtement georges ne le prends
pas mal mais était tout sauf le genre de
type extravagant se ressemblent un
informaticien coincé et si tu thaci et
que tu commences à jouer comme une
machine crois moi les gens vont se
méfier en plus les croupiers t'aimerons
beaucoup parce que tu leur donnes rade
pour boire faudra que je donne des
pourboires c'est ça c'est précisément
pour ça toi tu ne le ferai pas mettre
son alter ego lui oui d'accord
alors maintenant élise la gare d'europe
qu'est ce que tu as l'intention m dans
la une robe noire un petit truc c'est
que si je sais pas moi des talons écoute
je te le dis tout de suite il y au
change pour trie pas de talent aux
battues sera une [ __ ] chaussures de
mai mais ça peu drôle
d'accord je vais risques je trouve
intéressant c'est quoi sa mère d'une
robe de demoiselle d'honneur quoi eh
bien c'est tout ce que j'avais enfin
qu'est ce que vous croyez vous que
toutes les femmes un placard plage et de
vêtements cachant pour vous faire
plaisir
juste les plus sympas jeu sympa ou es ce
que vous avez trouvé ce magasin j'adore
offrir des cadeaux qui peuvent être
utiles oui c'est fait l'élevage de
chiens avaient cherché quelque chose en
particulier
oui non pas devant ces vieux cochon
droit hier
ma recherche elle légua ja où je suis
dans une troupe de théâtre m
et j'ai un bon rôle de prostituée je
cherche un costume plus seuls beaux
rôles qu'ils donnent aux femmes 1
alors c'est quoi des trottoirs les bars
dans un salon à domicile où ce rappel
hamon à ce serait plus sam du genre qui
s'affiche pas trop voix
et
je déteste les regards que vous posez
sûrement et je n'ai pas du tout envie
d'entendre vos réflexions en fait je
veux le silence total pendant cinq
minutes
[Musique]
hélas
non
[Musique]
m
un jour je suis là
[Musique]
agen
bienvenue monsieur bonnes choses ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
avec
c'est qu'on a pas parlé mais il faut
vraiment que je trouvais les toilettes
je viens d'arriver et à gommer ces
personnes
[Musique]
une seconde et où les pieds nus elle
demanderait bouddhiste avait la main
[Musique]
la vôtre coupé
merci monsieur merci nous disons
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]
lille est en toi j'ai envie d'aller aux
toilettes c'est épouvantable à plusieurs
problèmes quoi je suis bon compte mais
je peux pas le signal à georges pourquoi
ils me regardent jamais
martini s'est bouclé deux années de
suite monsieur
[Musique]
si je rate je fait rater l'équipe je
peux pas rater mois 23 samatan
[Musique]
80 dollars
jérémy de leurs deux chatons pardon
j'aimerais avoir ville dans l'art de
jetons s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
désolé j'ai un très gros matou dans la
gorge 200 $ pour la mise maximum génial
bien que vous n'aviez pas choisi la
bonne table ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a
pas eu un black jack
pardon je les apporte à boire
je suis occupé savané
monsieur monsieur
oui
monsieur ils repartent hd non non bien
sûr
je partage
je peux jouer à cette up pire tueur bien
loin dollars de jetons si grosse dépense
échange d'un pour 20 au 26 merci merci
minimum de 5 monsieur que le minimum est
simple
à
[Musique]
c'est ce que ta mère c'est plus rapide
que je ne pensais tu pense oui
enfin j'ai c'est quoi non je veux dire
tu réfléchis je crois tu devras éviter
ça devrait en fait ton cerveau sait quoi
faire lui alors ne fait pas
d'interférence ça peut être comme quand
le docteur de frappe le jugement ça
devient un réflexe n'est pas raison
d'accord le concept afin de le confier à
4 tu as 15
j'arrête voilà ça réfléchir j'ai parce
que moi tu vois j'ai vite de réfléchir
aux deux propositions je déjeune avec
ses tenues
alors laissez encore après c'est du rêve
[Musique]
je ne sais pas du tout ce qui t'a poussé
à penser sur ce jeu mais se vêtir bon
petit vieux truc complètement ça que
j'ai gagné c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
ben c'est pas trop tôt
[Musique]
quoi on avait dit aux heures quelle
heure il est alors le verdict
tu veux le savoir j'appelle ça joli
fiasco c'est tout si nous rater mauvaise
mise vous discutiez tout le temps comme
deux vieux copains et lui qui commencent
à miser dans les cinq premières minutes
rennes j'avais un jeu incroyable
ahurissant et georges j'étais nulle part
on avait une réunion
c'est vrai que j'étais un peu nerveuse
au départ mais vous avez vu nous il
assistait quoi c'était pas supportable à
regarder alors j'ai fichu le camp
comment est ce que vous avez perdu
ben en fait c'est bien défendu on a eu
de la veine et ça s'est calmé
on a perdu quelques mises mais on a
quand même récolté six mille dollars
qu'est ce que c'est que ces conneries
et ça c'est l'investissement de départ
les 10000 intacte au gem j'ai fait 75 $
sur mon propre ponyo est ce que je peux
les garder ses petits quoi et vous avez
dit qu'on partager les bénéfices 6 brins
chacun de vos familles dollars
ça aurait pu être un peu plus les
charges a donné un trop gros pourboire
au croupier 100 dollars j'étais excité
des petits rusé et on va les punir de
m'avoir chez celui-ci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec sur le dos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'hésite pas au fond sur nos mains clame
ouzou à 10 heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on arrose qu en fin de compte l'absence
du prof
[Musique]
le nom de tous là dessus j'invite mes
amis merci
pourquoi cette extravagance parce que je
peux me permettre à les intentions au à
l'argent facile bois attention pas un
george
non
je peux pas rester trop tard je
rencontre des recruteurs de mama terme
[Musique]
il y avait une fille dans ma classe
secondaire et l'état était en mai à sa
première année à 48 me coucher avec une
autre fille pour faire l'expérience
j'ai trouvé ce truc là très excitant qui
a déjà pensé toit et une autre fille
voilà j'ai même pas couché avec un type
depuis deux ans une fiche de 2 ans non
ouais georges et toi combien de temps
est-ce que ça fait
à peu près pareil
charge
[Musique]
est ce que tu es plus haut
je coucherais avec toi je re j
[Musique]
les sérieuses moi je m'inquiéterais à ta
place mon vieux ils n'ont bouteille s'il
vous plaît
non je crois qu'on s'est bien vengé deux
ans d'abstinence quoi cet appel
[Musique]
je suis vraiment désolé elise c'est une
longue histoire
c'est votre plus récent mémoire qui nous
intéresse je vous prie de m'excuser je
suis à disposer c'est quoi ça merde
souhaitent non t'es acheté une
décapotable
non elle est juste louer c'est pas une
bonne idée si je fais ce que je veux de
mon argent qui tombent dans le panneau
on veut faire de l'est pas t'avoir les
riches les gros bonnets quand il fallait
une bagnole n'y a rien de grave tu vois
pas que c'est exactement ce que les
casinos attendent quoi que tu ne puisses
du passé d'argent toute cette excitation
de ce faux éclat et paysans dans ta vie
ils sont prêts et andorre mac ou deux
repas gratuits et abêtissante offrant
toutes les consommations tu veux tu
perds ta lucidité ton investissement
tu perds tout
c'est juste pour rigoler et bientôt il
faudra que tu gagnes juste pour survivre
magarita cochonneries amène toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
déjà des voix est-ce que je peux tendre
et de signal pour quoi faire
écoute qu'il voit c'est tout je les
rendrai sur le poteau rate et vous
n'avez rien pris vous aviez l'intention
de parier sur les choix ce soir et vous
n'avez pas chez gucci le défi film à 200
dollars
[Musique]
le pauvre venir de le contre les femmes
au début
et la mode et design on y est tous les
ans à peine
bonjour vous vous travaillez oui juste
mais ça lui et moi aussi je travaille
[Musique]
soyez tranquille j'ai pas fini
afin que tu es déjà été
maintenant tu craques les joueurs
intéressants sont malades
et si je veux les coincer moi il faut
que je sois plus manag par contre quand
on est flic vous pouvez pas imaginer le
nombre de criminels idiot on voit les
joueurs sont pas mal non plus reste à la
table jusqu'à ce qu'il perde et qu'ils
rentrent chez eux disons pour la plupart
sont les pros que je connais ce mal je
vois oui et il y en a ici ce soir
ouais un seul ya souvent un c'est
visiblement un compteur le cac avait pas
très organisée après l'essai du menu
fretin
l'un 6 4 à 5 après midi par semaine bon
il ya une quelques centaines de dollars
va pas loin
il vient après midi
le soir parfois ils dépensent tous ces
gars en barre alors savoir est ce pas
gênant non c'est les gens qui
considèrent les casinos comme
l'organisme
c'est cela qu'on veut pas jouer pourquoi
les gens n'auraient pas le droit de
gagneur qu'on monte à une affaire de
cette envergure pour faire l'aumône et
on vous paie pour faire sa ba oui j'ai
de la chance
oui mais si vous étiez aussi malin que
vous lui dites vous seriez un provost 6
crever
pas de chance ce soir ça va pas du tout
ce pas ça ira quand même désolé parce
que nous on arrête la professeure on
s'est bien amusé mais non qu'est ce que
tu racontes vous êtes mon équipe jusqu'à
ce que je vous dise le contraire c'est
moi qui décide tu as bien compris en
quoi booster votre argent par les
fenêtres
pourquoi vous êtes toujours fauché
ma mère est morte 48 ans d'avoir trop bu
trop longtemps à son chevet je lui ai
demandé s'il avait des regrets
elle m'a répondu un seul je regrette
toutes ses nuits où j'étais sabra
et alors qu'est ce que tu veut se voir
d'autres
non
[Musique]
je vous surveille attention ou quoi vous
avez été coté côté comme joueur en fait
ça nous aide à soigner nos meilleurs
clients
non ça ne sera pas nécessaire car 25
mauvais votre nom howard awards
vous avez de la classe le dhimmi pour
nous 15
j'arrive 3 ou 13 18 c'est le suites de
luxe dans laquelle je vous ai installé
et vous pouvez commander tout ce que
vous voulez vous prenez le téléphone
c'est nous qui règle la note est très
bien
- j'arrêterai là si ça ne vous dérange
pas je serais heureux que vos métiers
bien entendu monsieur garde 24 grever la
décharge de votre décan
vous contrôlez très mal vos jeunes
poulets j'ai le regret de dire vous
seriez voulons juste un peu de
relâchement soute nous avons décidé de
mettre un terme à notre petit
arrangement
non non je vais leur parler ses yeux il
ne s'agit en fait
que de vous êtes si peu fiables vous
êtes trop à gros enjeu je formerai notre
équipe est là c'est fini
nous n'avons plus l'intention de payer à
partir d'aujourd'hui vous avez une
semaine pour nous rembourser et la note
se monte à présent à côte sans il pas là
une sublime c'est justement ce que je
pense vous n'êtes pas du tout sûr qu'ils
seront encore là pour une semaine
remboursez vos dettes professeur mars
on attendait les jeunes n'ont rien à
voir là-dedans personne ne dira le
contraire
de toute façon il fera autre chose
tandis que
vous finirez complètement ruinée au fond
d'une ruelle à jouer aux cartes preuve
de moi tu en as tu une semaine
[Applaudissements]
j'aime pas ça ça veut dire qu'ils m'ont
à l'oeil tu te rappelles parce que le
prof a dit qu'il nous manipule à soit
pas toujours inquiet ça veut bien que ça
durerait pas pourquoi on a fait ça pour
rigoler quoi on a voulu se marrer alors
coup revu et rigoler à leurs frais mon
vieux et ça va être super il tendit ils
enverront tout ce que tu désires un
filet mignon du champagne du caviar du
foie gras ce que tu veux fais-le et
amuse toi tu l'as bien mérité
merci scrutin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kononov génie on ne rigole plus qu'est
ce que ça veut dire que notre
investisseur monsieur or est mécontent
de ce qui est en train de se passer et
je sais que s'il ya un homme qui ne faut
pas mécontenter c'est bien lui on avait
un joli petit fils ont jusqu'à ce que
vous vous amusiez elle [ __ ] à la
poubelle
monsieur or est disposé à oubliée notre
petite entente contre la modique somme
de 500 mille dollars
quoi attendez mais de quelle entente est
ce que vous parlez non non non qu'ils
aillent se faire [ __ ]
je vais me le fais l'ennui tu vois c'est
que c'est pas toi c'est lui qui va tant
qu les hoquets où vous pensiez comprenez
l'argent pur joyau à l'église 500 mille
dollars
on a une semaine vous voulez qu'on fasse
un demi million de dollars en une
semaine c'est impensable en une semaine
notre équipe est un malade sinon quoi
ils nous tuent oui qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire c'est une histoire
vraie georges vous avez sept jours mais
merde quoi
quoi
c'est pas possible écoute marty balade
en barque
je devrai contre indiqué georges
emballer vos affaires on quitte le pays
on peut pas faire ça voyons j'ai pas
d'autre solution à [ __ ] je vais pas
refaire complètement con non vie sont
ici quoi réfléchir un peu pour une fois
tant qu'à faire ta ka prends ta
décapotable et descendre au mexique
hockey et nous on va rester ici on sera
qu à ta place et tout est d'abord même
qu'il ait djoudi les protocoles à celle
de 10 $ ce qui s'est passé mon ego riz
quelque part et il n'y a pas que moi
c'est tout le monde
[Musique]
comment on a pu en arriver là
qu'est ce que ça peut [ __ ] georges
tout ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on s'est
fait baiser
combien on a tous les trois mois j'ai
soixante mille toi georges 1
moi j'en ai 65 scott numéro 20 hockey ta
gueule on à 145 1000 $ à convertir ans
et demi million en une semaine ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut qu'on fasse 50
milles par jour aucun casino nous
laissera empoché trois cent cinquante
mille dollars de bénéfices baron jours à
ottawa à québec
et si une mouche à son fils sur toronto
je crois qu'on devrait sacrifier scott
quoi ils te surveille
alors s'il te surveille les risques de
surveiller les autres deux mois après
c'est une déduction logique
pendant ce temps il fait quoi il a plus
de raison de se cacher compte tout aussi
tu veux je m'en fous passe de table en
table pour les distraire d'accord montre
bien ce serait interdite dans tous les
autres que je m'écoute de toute façon tu
t'en fiches si toi qui disais que ça
pouvait pas durer
ok alors on joue comme avant ouais j'ai
organisé après y'a plus qu'à bien joué
si on fait aucune erreur on peut faire
50 mais par jour bon ouais et le petit
joueur est alors contre lui en action on
est bon qu'est ce que tu vois on dirait
qu'il atteint bondé quand elle essaie
lente
je regarde aussi te plaît a permis les
joueurs côté hong hao wang ching je le
connais pas il regarde ce qui suit c'est
elle mr ouai c'est une équipe c'est sûr
varanasi l'asiatique le petit frimeur et
la [ __ ]
une fois encore nos vallées cuisiner
j'arrête 16
18 je mise tout haut le maximum et à
10000 monsieur j'ai jeté un froid
vous devriez vous arrêtez un peu dessus
suivez-moi
mais pourquoi c'est bien ça vient
continu
je vous en prie
[Musique]
c'est l'aptitude triche aux cartes
étaient très occupés trésor écoute je te
l'aï déjà dit je connais personne qui a
envie de te faire une pique
suivez moi pourquoi on ne me touche pas
dû coûter si vous êtes aussi brillante
que vous le croyez suis certain que vous
savez sans l'ombre d'un doute qu'il est
dans votre intérêt de collaborer avec
moi c'est une menace
vous êtes déjà coupable de voies de fait
nous voulons avoir un entretien de
chance deuxième voie de fait vous ne
savez pas de quoi vous parlez
je sais que vous pouvez me demander
partir mais pas me retenir contre mon
gré monsieur l'expliquent merci
[Musique]
papiers d'identité vous plaît non non
non ils ont pas le droit de vous
demander ça et rendez moi mon sac s'il
vous plaît vous connaissez pas
l'expression saisi illicites
alors monsieur est avocat non je suis
vendeur de bible si vous voulez le
savoir et j'ai pas l'honneur de
connaître monsieur 2000 dollars en
liquide
pas mal du tout pour un petit vendeur
vous savez que vous n'avez pas le rap
fouillé et environ 5000 en jetant vrai
pression' ans n'est ce pas et après nous
confie ce qu'ont les jetons pour
commencer ils appartiennent au casino
non ils n'ont pas le droit vous
inquiétez pas ah oui oui parce que c'est
considéré comme du vol moi c'est une
cicatrice intéressante ça qui doit être
tabassés assez souvent toile si je tends
ce sont abandonnés prendre part
elle mettra jamais les pieds dans ce
cas-ci donc oui sinon sinon essayez
d'imaginer faut pas les provoquer l'insa
va c'est bien comme ça de toute façon
peu vrai allez allons nous en excuser
moi fait gaffe quand tu seras dalle par
quiconque ils ont l'air de bien
connaître leurs droits et où est la
fille sanders ne vous avez fait combien
je sais pas 400 un peu près 1000 moi
c'est tout me sens donc 2000 entre quoi
c'est pas super ils ont probablement
déjà prévenu ottawa maintenant
t'inquiète ça va aller ils savent pas
qui on est
[Musique]
moi je dis qu'on file direct sur vegas
ouais moi étudiants avec 180 mille
dollars en liquide dans un avion pour
las vegas
on peut se coller des sacs en plastique
sur le corps et en cash et un peu aussi
dans nos orifices ne sais pas comment tu
imagines la taille de mon vagin mais ils
ne seront pas plus que quelques cents
bah alors on se fait virer l'argent là
bas à l'adresse d'un hôtel n'ont pas
changé d'âme est trop importante pour
passer par une banque ça prend des jours
à dijon [ __ ] merde bah quoi l'histoire
c'est si seulement ça pouvait il finit
tard
[Musique]
tu arrives tu à réfléchir moyer trop
tard suivre les deux heures
[Musique]
mme royal a perdu faut qu'on aille se
coucher
georges
monsieur monsieur monsieur non excusez
moi un désir une carte nord la banda
les gars les gars les gars fait il nous
manque 20 mille dollars ou 6 ans je sais
comment ça tu sais quoi qu'est ce que tu
sais un scot ben montréal a perdu
je suis désolé serait du marché paraît
du marché via fichu voir ce qu'ils
traitent j'en ai mal de conneries j'ai
plus rien quoi qu'est-ce qu'ils habitent
jeudi j'ai plus rien ou merdique on sait
que je contrôle tout ce que tu as à
partir de maintenant j'aurais dû faire
du sun pour 2,5 pour nous c'est vraiment
une merde débile pour la toute première
fois de ma courte vie il ya eu je ne
sais pas une petite période disons un
mois où je pouvait savourer une bonne
heure de la sécurité financière touche
poubelles m'endormir sans être
totalement de celle des palaces à l'idée
d'avoir à trouver le moyen de survivre
un jour de plus que le sucre et tu
gaspilles encore un seul sou de langage
qui font mal à la peau merde
j'ai perdu mes dollars sur le jeu avec
la roue qui tourne commence à perdre à
des espèces de jeu dont je connais même
pas le nom du nouveau 20 dollars quoi g
j'ai dit à une fille hier soir qu'on
irait prendre un verre
merci
gel
je préfère y retourner
t'es pas obligé georges non il nous faut
de l'argent je vais aller à regagner
plein comme un demi million pourra pas
on aura besoin de nouvelles idées
je sais plus quoi faire quand tu as joué
je suivais la méthode pour vous devriez
avoir encore un coup de chance sûrement
vous pouvez pas trouver un peu d'argent
je sais pas moi on hypothèque en votre
maison ou une avance sur votre salaire
je suis locataire hockey et vend des
voix de voitures au mois ce sera déjà ça
tu veux rire et fait 44 sumo plus que la
nature
autant dire que vous n'avez rien ça tout
ce qu'il est un joueur est toujours de
l'espoir
oui c'est chouette en tout cas je dois
dire que ce que j'espère c'est qu'on
finira pas tous à la morgue
[Musique]
écoute et quelle heure
environ trois heures c'est rien
oh non par les biens on vous a tous
repérés
d'accord on ne comprendra rien son
histoire et tu nous rend d'abord le
pognon tue nous a volés ensuite si tu
puta
j'ai une autre idée je te donne ça
uniquement si tu m'appelles un taxi ne
faut pas le magal
soit quelque chose de cas si tu veux
qu'on aille à l'hôpital
devant j'ai une dent qui vaut ce fait
tout tout humain trop fort tu l'a mordu
c'est la première fois que je me bagarre
j'espère que ça va aller vous êtes
parfait ça va ça va ça va
mais tu trembles non je vibre oh merde
georges tu as pris de la coke charge
c'est ce truc là c'est écrit en chinois
tu vas nous dire ce que tu as valet oui
ou merde c'est un petit remontant
mais je crois que dans les tromperies
[Applaudissements]
genre j'arrête
j'ai vraiment désiré
tu crois que ça va aller très bien
tu pourrais jouer
ouais
ok l afic j'ai vu tout à l'heure et
travailler à la caisse et elle m'a parlé
d'une simple un truc privé oiac du black
jack
je sais mais je vois pas quoi faire
d'autre
c'est notre dernier espoir
est-ce que c'est long juste à côté
on est d'attaqué vous croyez moi je suis
pas sûr de les prénoms et attendez quoi
j'imagine qu'il ya un prix d'entrée dans
ce genre de truc ne sois pas étonné
qu'il fasse une fouille corporelle
je veux dire à fond quoi réfléchir
georges c'est déjà assez difficile
d'arriver à entrer dans un bar
clandestin alors imagine ici comme
qu'est ce que tu attends
allez venez on s'en va on vient pour
jouer vous avez dû vous tromper de porte
c'est rebecca qui nous envoie
c'est une mitrailleuse c'est un mp
singla marine ce sont surtout les
services secrets qui s'en servent il vit
chez ses parents il ya beaucoup de jeux
vidéo chez eux
si on boit trop on pourrait bien se
retrouver au fond d'une cale de bateau
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
on est baisé
quoi pourquoi il joue avec un seul
paquet et chaque fois qu'il donne il
brasse il faut s'en aller tout de suite
le tir hors de question on est entré on
joue tu es malade c'est georges qui va
jouer surtout tu connais les algorithmes
beaucoup mieux que nous quoi ils vont
nous laisser en trois minutes la mise
commence à 10000 et il joue beaucoup
trop vite
georges non
chargement comment mise la martingale
je vous signale que ça nous laisse à
peine sa main avant la faillite complète
bageois il faut mettre le paquet on va
essayer de jouer vite et bien dix mille
[Musique]
15 18 21
bah
[Rires]
miss 20
[Musique]
[Rires]
15-10
quarante scott 16 crever
[Musique]
déjà 70 80 80 milles
un naturel
[Musique]
50 des profits ok on y va sans fil voilà
cent mille
[Musique]
j'ai tiré oui je sais
11 tirs je sais carte 15
dieu mon dieu le maire bien perdu 17
arrêts
[Musique]
16 le croupier tirs sur 16
ces projets
copier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas ce qu'a fait
on fait quoi qu'est ce que tu as dit
sans doute rester stylée
10 140
à 60
et on remet ça si on allait prendre un
verre avant d'accord mois sa cote quoi
je te dis qu'on devrait aller prendre un
verre
pourquoi ça roule l'argent c'est moi tu
sais le bordel qu'est ce qu'il ya ça
fonctionne quoi
quoi il est temps de les pendre vert
scott mais pourquoi tu insistes qu'est
ce qui se passe à rete je te dis qu'on a
besoin de voir quelque chose
jusque thibault justement je te dis en
moi je commence à voir
je m'excuse mais vous avez un problème
non non c'est rien n'y a aucun problème
mais là pas de problème pas de problème
alors jouer bonjour non un décompte des
cartes à 20
nos cartes sont parfaitement en règle le
paquet est incomplet allez-y quand elle
vous verrez il y en a 48
il en manque 4 2 10-2 as tu peux même
vous donner les couleurs
non non non ok écouter mais c'est pas
grave on a sonné au nom vous n'irez
nulle part nathan mayer des 0,5 me dire
quoi il veut compter les cartes lui
aussi haut mais comme quand tu ailles
biothermica conduisent à tout petit
journal yen il dit il dit qu'il n'aime
pas qu'on triche il va reprendre son
argent et sont allés ça ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup voient cela comme tout cas tout
mis encore il dit que vous avez deux
hommes qui sont très mal à tenir on pas
ici fava lui il a une dizaine d'hommes
sur sept étages ils sont armés ils sont
membres des triades attiyah au maillot
en plus il a un tireur d'élite
postés sur l'immeuble en face en somme
lenval routine à houla il a un fusil hk
une arme de précision de la police
pointée sur votre tête il dit que si
vous osez faire le moindre mouvement
vers lui votre cerveau deviendra
d'apurer
ja rule a et il dit que vous deviez vous
douté qu'il ne viendrait pas seuls et à
sa soeur alors il va s'en aller mais
free like a wheel clean il a t'on cours
il dit qu'il faut que les trois
étudiants sont avec lui
il a aussi dit que le type sur le toit
et la dé la zéro nid des balles de
cuivre dixons ça peut être vous dire
quelque chose
thierry font tout de suite j'arrive pas
à le croire
je croyais que vous étiez faux si
j'avais rien dit on y sera encore quoi
je suis représentant de fruits de mer
d'accord et qu'est ce que vous disiez à
charge alors celui qui m'a dit de dire
n'importe quoi et avec conviction
[Musique]
faux vivent encore à place juste pour le
raconter ce bateau est ce qu'on va
continuer on peut cacher l'argent sous
la voiture
on va rassembler tout l'argent qu'on a
et on va lui donner on lui dira qu'on a
fait tout ce qui était possible de faire
écho regrette c'est comme ça mais
attends on est en avance il nous reste
plein temps on a encore plusieurs jours
on pourrait gonfler notre magog charge
c'est impossible on n'ira pas plus loin
faut savoir s'arrêter
la plata
c'est fini
[Musique]
quel lieu de rendez-vous ridicule vous
voulez l'argent oui ou non et coûte 300
milles c'est pas suffisant il vous
restait quatre jours pleins on a eu des
ennuis
barré par tous d'ailleurs vous ne nous
avez pas beaucoup aidé allez on va
régler ça si tu veux ou ou 2000 argent
il va venir
mais on attend notre investisseur coup
vous ne pensez tout de même pas qu'on
allait vous filer tout le paquet sans
savoir une salle tout quoi tu pas
[Musique]
bah oui ça
cette façon de faire est prêté au tapis
elle ne vient pas de moi dit alors vous
avez quelque chose pour moi
oui ça va arriver
[Musique]
il faut que je vous explique l'oiseau
com
[Musique]
permettez ce contrat
à
on a fait notre possible monsieur ya 300
millions c'est tout ce qu'on a pu
récolter à vous vous doutez bien que
nous ne pourrions pas gagner 500 mille
dollars en une semaine c'est 5 me c'est
impossible c'est vrai c'est impossible
ouais c'était un peu irréaliste c'est
vrai
malgré tout trois cent mille c'est un
bel effort
la dette est réglé et merci bien entendu
alors ça va aller ça ira comme sur des
roulettes retourner vite à vos études
mes jeunes amis et surtout oublier les
casinos en fait donc quelque chose dans
la vie alors
il vaut mieux faire comme s'il ne
s'était jamais rien passé d'accord vous
ne me connaissez pas
oh merde non et oui au maire en quoi oh
georges
à ses jours bonne chance à des gas
alors qu'est ce que tu veux faire
maintenant toi moi j'ai un cours dans 10
minutes et après je sais pas je vais
rentrer je suis sûr c'est un boulot
enfin essayer de faire quelque chose de
ma vie j'ai un truc pour toi charge
je les ai mis de côté au cas où
j'en ai pas besoin tu en as et pour
finir une diversité sans être obligés
d'être serveuse enfin je sais pas quoi
dire c'est fou écoute alors
je te dire la prochaine
mais si jamais
c'est pas du cherche à 10 ans un ami
coeur en plus ordinaire tue le fifig
[Musique]
à
ils jouent aux cartes
[Musique]
je m'appelle ellis